- [Narrator:] Welcome to 100 seasons of Gridiron Heights!
- [Robert Irsay:] SHHHH, Baltimore will hear you! What a prank.
- Maybe nobody noticed the butt thing.
- OK, I LOST, SO SEW IT BACK ON!
- I’M SCRAMBLING TO FIND THE SEAM!
- [Narrator:] Gridiron Heights began in 1920 as league propaganda.
But the show didn’t gain popularity until its 1950s breakout star.
- I’m Johnny Unitas, see, and I shoot really well.
- Yeah, I had a Johnny Unitas Gridiron Heights lunchbox growing up.
Who didn’t?
- [Interviewer:] The question was how do you feel about the Niners loss?
- Oh, I stopped feeling things a long time ago.
- [Narrator:] The '80s and '90s featured more beloved characters.
- OH NO. STOP, IT’S ME, WILLIAM “REFRIGERATOR” PERRY.
OH, THAT’S MY STOMACH!
- SLIME TIME? I THOUGHT YOU WAS TALKIN' ABOUT PRIME TIME!
Don’t forget to watch me on DIAMOND HEIGHTS, RIGHT AFTER THIS.
- DUHHHHH WHY CAN’T I GET A RING?!
I never really liked my character on the show.
- YEAH, SAME, I DON’T SOUND LIKE THAT.
- [Narrator:] And while several “lost episodes” have been banned over the years,
the show has lasted 100 seasons thanks to the many classics.
- Where should I put my congrats card?!
- ELI, NO!
- AHHHHHHHH!
- Hello youngsters,
if you enjoyed this moving picture and would like to watch more,
simply subscribe by sending all your personal information and exactly
3 American cents to 100 Gridiron Heights Way.
Thank you, and remember,
only WE can take down the commies!